d'avoir la caméra et quelques minutes
plus tard 17h03 un autre vol regardez
alors Jérôme qui s'est passé on avait
vous en avez eu ras-le-bol c'est quoi
c'est un moment qu'est-ce qui vous êtes
beaucoup volé je sais pas si je suis
beaucoup volé mais en tous les cas je
pense qu'on est nombreux en France à
l'être je pense que il y a beaucoup de
commerçants qui doivent se retrouver
dans ces images c'est le quotidien de
beaucoup de commerçants le mien la
semaine dernière j'en ai marre on en a
tous ras-le-bol en fait on en a marre de
se retrouver face à ces gens-là qui
ne craignent rien en fait il se rendent
compte qu'ils peuvent faire ce qu'ils
veulent c'est pour ça c'est ce que vous
avez dit vous avez dit il peut faire ce
qu'ils veulent parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'était la seule solution vous êtes qui
c'est qui c'est vous qui avez pris cette
décision d'afficher d'afficher les
images de de vos voleurs ça s'est passé
mardi vous le voyez sur les images mardi
dernier et puis et puis je dis je suis
allé porter plainte j'ai hésité parce
que fait la queue deux heures et puis
après à la police on vous dit on va
faire ce qu'on peut mais
n'espérez rien il y a tellement de gens
qui attendaient après moi que je me suis
fait que et puis samedi je me suis dit
je vois pas pourquoi on pourrait faire
ça en France aujourd'hui donc je me suis
dit il faut y aller
mais je croyez moi encore une fois on
est on est nombreux dans cette situation
là je vous remercie de m'inviter mais
des commerçants vous pourriez un invité
non mais justement de perdre mal de
monde qui ont pensé à le faire aussi qui
ont déjà fait c'est une pratique qui
vient de plus en plus courante vous avez
des petites pancartes on vous a posé des
questions à qui lui a raison de le faire
ou pas
Jérôme Jérôme pourquoi vous étiez
vous êtes dans un
vous étiez dans une démarche vous êtes
dit façon aujourd'hui quoi c'est quoi
ils vont être même si on les retrouve
ils vont être relâchés au bout de au
bout de quelques temps et on voilà donc
alors déjà il faut les retrouver c'est
la première chose donc c'est quand même
pas évident et puis ensuite de toute
façon une heure après et encore une
heure ils vont ressortir est-ce qu'ils
font chez moi sur ces images ils l'ont
fait une semaine avant dans d'autres
commerces on se rend compte qu'en fait
notre métier à nous c'est de vendre eux
c'est de voler ils sont ils sont très
forts pour ça
organisé oui parce que là vous le voyez
pas mais il y a des bips sur les
vêtements mais ils ont des sacs ils sont
équipés de sac spéciaux qui font que
quand on passe sur les portiques qui
sont derrière vous ça sonne pas et puis
le personnel bah moi je forme pas des
vigiles je forme des vendeuses et des
vendeurs sur et ils sont là pour
accompagner les clients il y avait du
monde dans le magasin donc qu'est-ce
qu'on doit faire est-ce qu'on doit
laisser faire ou pas d'afficher leur
visage est-ce que vous allez dire moment
c'est plus peur j'ai plus peur parce que
parce que c'est trop fréquent il faut
savoir que ce que vous voyez chez moi
c'est c'est encore une fois dans tous
les commerces de France et c'est à peu
près 2 à 5% du chiffre d'affaires de ces
commerçants mais non sur ton ce moment
on abandonne on a déjà trop de trop de
choses qui font qu'on a du mal à s'en
sortir c'est en plus on doit rajouter ça
Gilles Verdez pour vous c'est une
mauvaise
mauvaise technique très mauvaise
habitude comme d'habitude avec vous je
comprends votre désarroi votre colère
mais tu fais rien toi en fait non mais
en fait c'est ça tu comprends rien de
justifie la vendetta rien ne justifie
d'exposer d'afficher les gens comme ça
c'est pour les réseaux sociaux
c'est quoi ta solution voilà j'ai envie
de savoir c'est quoi ta solution la
solution c'est la police voilà d'accord
vous allez les voir et vous disent la
vérité oui vraiment monsieur vous avez
bien fait de le faire parce que c'est ce
qu'il faut faire mais on pourra rien
faire je vous dis la vérité vous perdez
votre temps vous en dit ça ou pas vous
l'ont dit ouais c'est tout à fait
quoi mais on ne peut pas vous faites
quoi mais on peut pas se faire juste
histoire même serrer quoi si vous avez
la bonne solution non quel est votre
solution c'est la police plus d'effectif
la plainte c'est très bien mais pas bah
oui mais vous dites ah excusez-moi c'est
illégal monsieur c'est lui qui risque un
an de prison mais quand vous avez vu ce
qui se passe sur les réseaux sociaux oui
vous avez vu les le harcèlement qui a
sur les réseaux sociaux vous avez vu les
gens qui m'ont des vidéos qui montrent
des photos de gens et lui donc lui
aujourd'hui en fait c'est pas c'est pas
pour retrouver les affaires qui ont été
volées c'est juste en fait c'est pour
marquer le compte c'est en fait il s'est
dit voilà je vais essayer de marquer le
coup je vais essayer de faire que ça se
reproduise plus Mathieu
on est dans un pays je l'ai déjà dit
tout est fait pour les délinquants rien
n'est fait pour les gens honnêtes quand
je me suis fait cambrioler et que j'ai
été à la police je leur ai dit est-ce
qu'il y a une chance il y avait de
montre avec le numéro et Monsieur il y a
aucune chance on va même pas chercher
voilà ce qui m'avait dit on va même pas
chercher donc effectivement ce que vous
comprenez ce qu'il a fait bien sûr que
je comprends qu'il le fasse dans les
grandes
puisque c'est très grave de mettre le
visage des saisons sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est une vendetta qu'est-ce que
vous dites pas du tout il est d'abord la
loi juste se trompe c'est que 1 donc
voler c'est pas grave non c'est pas ça
fragile c'est moins grave oui si on met
pas leur visage 1 on les arrêtera pas et
deux si on les arrête 24 heures après
ils sont dehors merci encore madame
tobira qu'est-ce qu'on fait quel est le
rapport avec mettre la photo des gens le
rapport c'est que maintenant ils sont
affichés on peut les repérer on peut
savoir quand ils arrivent qui va les
repérer vous moi déjà les gens qui ont
des boutiques qui vont se passer les
vidéos entre eux personne n'a envie
d'avoir tu sais tu sais les gens qui le
seul contre argument c'était en Chine en
Chine si tu payes pas tes impôts par
exemple sur un grand écran mini player
days Paypal ses impôts même si tu
traverses voilà alors c'est les extrêmes
évidemment en France quand la police ne
peut plus rien pour toi on passe d'une
démocratie à une anarchie c'est-à-dire
qu'on se déforme soi-même c'est ce que
fait monsieur il y a pas d'autre
solution en tous les cas quand on
demande une solution qu'est-ce que tu
amènes rien merci Gilles monsieur est-ce
que vous avez pensé est-ce que vous avez
pensé que vous allez faire un tel buzz
non non mais ça a été aujourd'hui
c'était le sujet dont les gens ont le
plus parlé et qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à Gilles Verdez quand il vous
dit que c'est pas bien ce que vous avez
fait
je m'agace gilbertez
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que de
victimes je suis passé à coupable c'est
ça oui en prison vous risquez monsieur
oui
franchement c'est très grave c'est la
très grave j'attaquer
je souhaite pas qu'il a un enterrement
je rappelle ce qui risque moi je pense à
vous vous risquez ça tu penses
à tout le monde il veut faire plaisir à
tout le monde
juste pour préciser mon propos j'incite
pas les commerçants à faire comme moi je
vous dis juste moi je veux bien assumer
et j'assumais responsabilités j'assume
les conséquences de mon geste je
reconnais que parfois ça m'ennuie de
voir toute cette exposition de ces
individus même si c'est moi qui les
provoqué je pensais pas que ce serait
autant relayé je pensais pas recevoir
autant de centaines de messages de
clients ou de commerçants qui m'ont dit
mais vous avez eu 1000 fois raison nous
on l'a jamais fait vous avez eu raison
de le faire
conséquence pour eux c'est quoi
les conséquences pour moi oui les
conséquences pour eux c'est rien mais
encore une fois moi je suis un petit
commerçant à Amiens qui est une ville
remarquable d'ailleurs il y a pas plus
de vol et de délinquance à Amiens
qu'ailleurs mais il faut le faire réagir
là haut et leur dire donner les moyens
la police on a la vidéo sur rien
les moyens pardon au 24 milliards au
service public j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure ça va vous voyez donc il y a des
images bien sûr qu'ils veulent faire et
la pub la police apprécie moi je me suis
fait piquer mon scooter dans le parking
le mec il est très très con mon parking
il est truffé de caméra alors il faut
pas donner les caméras pour pas qu'on
reconnaisse le mec ça n'a rien à voir
ils veulent mon scooter
sur les réseaux voilà vous donnez bien
sûr que la police doit avoir les
signalements les caméras tout le
matériel mais c'est pas à nous
d'exploiter des caméras de surveillance
qu'on sait pas le faire c'est ça qui me
choque Valérie bénaïne vous êtes
d'accord oui je comprends tout à fait
l'exaspération et je sais je comprends
que vous soyez arriver à un point de
non-retour et que vous disiez c'est ça
parce que je sais pas que je sais plus
quoi faire né moi je suis légaliste donc
évidemment je peux me mettre que du côté
du droit alors oui ça c'est emmerdant le
droit je suis désolé oui ça fait chier
le droit peut-être
elle a raison elle elle défend les trucs
qui vont chier par ailleurs en vérité
c'est elle qui est dans le système
de bonheur c'était un autre monde à
l'époque
j'ai même et par ailleurs je je j'irai
même plus loin je j'aurais peut-être
même peur pour vous monsieur parce que
on ne sait jamais qui vous mettez en
vidéo qui peut-être à une bande qui peut
être un machin et qui peut ensuite venir
vouloir recevoir donc on fait rien alors
on fait quoi Valérie Bénaïm et ben on
fait quoi on va donner évidemment à la
police alors évidemment la police
évidemment tout ce que mais le monde est
imparfait la France est imparfaite le
droit est imparfait mais on se met du
côté droit on fait quoi et ben on va
porter plainte voilà
je réponds à Cyril qu'est-ce que tu fais
toi à ce moment-là qu'est-ce que tu fais
tu vas tu mets la vidéo ici le mec
revient tu lui casse la gueule
maintenant qu'on a fait ça qu'on a été
déposé plainte et qu'on a l'identité des
personnes parce que la police
tu fais comparution au tribunal tu mets
du ferme et ça veut dire que les
policiers n'ont pas travaillé pour nous
c'est ce que je veux dire
une fois que la police t'a montré à la
police t'as pas mis sur les réseaux
parce que toi tu veux pas qu'est-ce que
fait la police quand il y a un
enlèvement elle met sur les réseaux
quand il y a enlèvement d'enfants et
tout
ça vraiment
urgent bien sûr euh juste Jérôme Valérie
bénaïmcote elle est plus mesurée que
gilberté il a dit qu'elle est dans le
côté du droit pour un moment vous dites
moi j'en peux plus mais moi je me dis
tant pis je vais prendre pour les autres
la lessive prenez un nom de prison
la décision de justice je prendrai un
avocat
parce que malheureusement quand tu
rentres dans un dans un commissariat de
police il y a ça dans le dossier et de
toute manière il serait arrêté il y
aurait déjà 3 ans à peu près 3 ans à peu
près d'instruction avant que eux déjà
soit en prison ou toute manière il ne
risque rien c'est pour ça même si même
s'ils sont même s'ils sont d'accord ça
serait resté sur le sujet Kelly
et puis après c'est vrai que j'ai plus
peur pour lui qu'autre chose parce que
ces mecs là on sait pas de quoi ils sont
capables s'ils sont capables de faire ça
ils sont capables de revenir et de vous
et de vous embêter vous donc c'est plus
simple
et tout ça va lui coûter 6000 euros par
mois avec les charges
c'est pas le thème de la boutique on est
on est ouvert un mardi alors c'est c'est
même pas les soldes c'est le lendemain
on a certes du monde mais mais
aujourd'hui les commerçants vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure les gilets jaunes
on a traversé des périodes quand même
très compliquées je suis à Paris donc on
peut avoir une pensée pour tous les
commerçants parisiens ils payent des
loyers exorbitants et qui aujourd'hui et
bah RAM pour avoir des clients j'ai une
idée moi dites-moi pour que ce que vous
ne mettez pas des écrans qui restitue ce
que la caméra filme le voleur tout d'un
coup il se voit mais non mais en train
de voler
faut arrêter on peut pas filmer les gens
en train de commettre des délits on
n'est pas dans un film et moi et moi
j'ai une question à vous poser à Cyril
aussi là vous dites on peut afficher des
gens on en peut plus de toi
vas-y pose ta question on en peut plus
excusez-moi de mon point de vue mais je
sais mais tu es vraiment tu es la France
de l'échec
de la légalité
vous pouvez pas prendre leur défense
exactement d'accord je prends pas leur
défense je dis que vous n'avez pas le
droit des exposer et parlons deux vous
filmez des voleurs d'habits d'accord
donc en cas d'agression de choses plus
graves si on va dans cette logique là on
va donc filmer des gens qui tapent les
autres dans la rue mais sont les je vais
te dire comment aujourd'hui
tu fais quoi des murs entiers
d'affichage de délinquants mais attendez
on peut pas faire justice soi-même en
France on n'a pas dit ça
quelle est ta solution là la police la
police
arrête pas le temps ce qu'on dit je vous
entends mais c'est pas bon j'aimerais
que ta voix qui a pas de solutions
aujourd'hui les commerçants ils portent
pardon les commerçants ils ont pas le
temps puisque toute façon mais bien sûr
vous passez des heures et des heures à
porter plainte je connais les
commerçants qui toutes les semaines vont
porter plainte on leur dites quoi ces
gens-là et ben c'est ce qu'il faut faire
bah il faut payer quelqu'un qui sait que
ça alors donc vous savez ce qu'ils vont
faire les commerçants qui vont plier
boutique
pas mal j'ai dit que toutes les caméras
c'est pas ça on verra tous les gens
voient que tout est surveillé
je suis très heureuse de vous voir vous
êtes Damien je suis né j'étais au foyer
pas très loin d'Amiens moi quand je sors
d'un supermarché aux carte d'identité on
m'affiche sur tous les réseaux et vous
vous avez affiché des voleurs je suis
d'accord avec vous parce que justement
si tout le monde faisait ça les
commerçants qui payent 3000 euros et qui
font pas énormément d'argent de loyer
peuvent justement se défendre parce que
la police a énormément de dossiers moi
j'aimerais vous donner en guise de
conclusion un avis c'est que tous les
jeunes qui sont en banlieue qui
cherchent un travail prenez-les à la
porte c'est des gens comme moi des gens
vivent et justement vous voulez prendre
en turc
justement ça pourrait aider et donc
merci
Hafida tes idées excuse-moi je t'adore
chérie mais c'est pourri ça va lui
coûter 6000 euros par mois il a il a pas
les moyens déjà de s'en sortir avec ça
Géraldine en fait vous servez de lanceur
d'alerte parce que aujourd'hui la police
elle est débordée et la justice elle est
malade et il y a un sentiment d'impunité
que de toute façon quoi qu'on fasse
c'est vous qui êtes le bourreau et que
eux sont les victimes donc en fait il y
a impunité il y a l'axisme et il y a de
toute façon ça ne sert à rien donc je
pense qu'en fait c'est comme ça qu'on
est la mafia au départ je sais pas si
vous avez vu le parrain en fait c'est
parce que l'État ne peut rien faire pour
vous protéger et donc il y a des millise
privées et il y a des matières donc
c'est désolant mais je pense que par
votre action je pense que peut-être il
peut y avoir un sorte de réveil de de
nos instances du garder ça parce qu'il
faut changer la loi je pense pas les
commerçants à faire ce que j'ai fait
surtout pas c'est bien pour ça que je
n'incite pas à faire ça moi je l'ai fait
j'espère que les plus hauts sommets de
l'État c'est peut-être prétentieux mais
c'est grâce à vous et grâce à l'élection
de Cyril qui vont prendre conscience de
ce qui se passe et aujourd'hui il faut
donner les moyens à la police vous allez
au commissariat on va prendre celui
d'Amiens mais c'est là juste là
en fait la police fait le boulot c'est
la justice qui est beaucoup plus
on va on va perdre du temps pour aller
chercher on va les retrouver ils
arrêtent et ils ressort on va prendre un
risque je suis allé les chercher
on va exactement on va aller on va on va
les prendre ils vont sortir au bout de
deux heures donc à quoi ça sert on va
perdre du temps on va on a on a d'autres
choses à faire pour et à chaque fois ils
sont dégoûtés parce que les mecs
ressortent au bout de deux heures et ils
leur font des doigts bah oui c'est vrai
mais oui ce débat il est fou en fait on
est en train de se demander si quelqu'un
qui a subi un vol donc une victime est
allé trop loin donc s'il est coupable
ouais c'est qui les coupables c'est ceux
qui respectent rien qui vole et qui
mettent des entreprises dans la merde ou
c'est ceux qui veulent simplement que la
loi soit appliquer donc moi je comprends
ce qu'elle fait monsieur bravo encore
une fois faut se demander poser la
question pourquoi vous l'avez fait parce
que quand on m'a porté plainte il ne se
passe rien et moi pardon je ne vois même
pas le problème d'afficher la tête d'un
voleur on s'en fout il a volé c'est
c'est de sa faute quel est le problème
pour toi pour toi non Gilles là tu as
fait il va trop long afficher la tête
d'un voleur qui dit que c'est le voleur
la présomption
[Applaudissements]
dangereux mais vous ne connaissez vous
le connaissez pas la loi qui dit mais on
a beaucoup on a pas le droit pourquoi
vous vous et moi on a pas le droit
d'utiliser des caméras de surveillance
parce que rien ne dit
trucage qui est pas eu détournement qui
est pas humanipulation c'est interdit
pour ça c'est fou ce que vous dites pour
les assurances
vous êtes tous des délinquants
de te faire insulter sur Twitter mais en
fait tu te rends compte de ce que tu dis
mais je ne suis pas dit qu'il a volé il
est là tu t'es fait faire une opération
des yeux t'inquiète arrête du cul ou
quoi il est là
impossible
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'il faisait du rangement de
votre magasin
offrir quelques affaires naturels
ce serait plus simple de demander pardon
oui à 93%
[Applaudissements]